so I'm I'm here with famous filmmaker
Davis Guggenheim
I'm smirking when you say this famous
anything you you are I am Inconvenient
Truth the waiting for Superman
great teacher project amongst others but
just to rewind I'd like to talk more
about all trickly all the stuff that
you've worked on but but how did you get
started I have always been fascinated
when I see people who are filmmakers huh
there's no there's not a traditional
career how did you get started my father
was a great documentarian he no one knew
who he was he rode his bike to work but
he made all these great social justice
documentaries and he was my hero but
after college I moved to LA to not make
it doctor what did he do in college what
did you think you were gonna do I was a
history major and I wanted to get out of
my father's shadow like and and I moved
up to Hollywood I'm not gonna make
documentaries but but you did you have
an idea of what you were going it was
gonna make Hollywood movies okay it's
gonna make I was gonna be he makes
documentaries I'm gonna be a hotshot
Hollywood director but you had embraced
this filmmaking aspect of your I mean
that's yes that's not as big of a
departure for most people that seems
pretty close so kids if doctors can
become a lawyer you know kids of lawyers
can become an accountant but no one no
one is as kid of a documentarian and
becomes a doctor it's a degenerative
it's a degenerative skill that's passed
down you never understand that right
because your your your family your
father would have judged you if you
would become a tradition no no I think I
don't think I could have frankly I think
very dyslexic not good in school and so
became tuned to other things
my brain was tuned to other things so
what you saw your father and you saw
film crews and you saw and that did
right kind of resonate with you it's a
goodness circus
yeah and a good lights cables cameras I
mean what your father did did strongly
influenced yes this I'm gonna go to
Hollywood and he was a hero to me I just
could never be as good as him imagine if
your hero was Superman or Iron Man
you'll never be as good as that so
youyou thought that like oh it would be
amazing to be a great documentarian like
my dad but I'm never gonna be able to do
that he won 12 he won four Academy
Awards it was nominated 12 times so you
started off saying no one knows who he
is and he rides his bike to work and I
he was a big but no one knew who he was
so he had the double threat I'm totally
anonymous and but but also remarkable in
his in his what were some of his he made
films about the Johnstown Flood the Klu
Klux Klan the Kennedys those out there
beautiful movies beautiful movie yeah of
course yeah beautiful beautiful
wonderful movies and so you have you
that is like just the high-water mark
and you could you could maybe not you
can do that but you can do a big
Hollywood blockbusters right and there's
more like we talked about this earlier
the the son finding his identity outside
of his father like you know just to just
to follow in his footsteps would have
been pathetic for me as an 18 year old
so I had to go off and make it on my own
and everybody but how did you think
about it I you know it's not I mean did
you think about what are my odds of
being able to succeed you know I did the
math is it visible yeah and and so but
you still decided to do it oh you mean
to go to Hollywood well yeah well
filmmaker generally Hollywood in
particular yeah but the like the odds of
me being a doctor or a lawyer was worse
it was like it was not even possible so
it's just there were no odds so you were
you were full at you were naive you you
like the Mets winning the World Series
you knew so you were just right after
college so you're the 21 22 where'd you
go to college you went I went to NYU and
then Brown NYU and brown and history and
what did you at brown and I remember
walking around the campus of brown
senior year going documentaries are kind
of over
Ken Burns as Ken Burns there's no place
for me
like it'll never like the establishment
is there and there's no there's in its
set the things I'll never change so he
started in when you transferred to brown
yeah you're a history major the entire
time yeah but film was always kind of in
your mind went to NYU just study film
write was famous for that and after a
year I said this I don't like this it's
not for me I'm gonna study history and
why is because I think NYU at the time
was very practically based it was
teaching a lot of skills that I think a
lot a lot of people a lot of my fellow
students really dug and learn from but I
knew that and from what my father taught
me that the the Corp the key piece which
is which is the ultimate thing to learn
is storytelling and I wasn't seeing
anyone who taught storytelling so why
not learn history or the great and and
you know my father should have
influenced me he says you know if you
learn to write if you read a lot if you
sort of figure that part out then you
can figure out stories but the path the
beginning again filmmaker is not about
the equipment or the technique it's
about stories and so when you were
sitting in a history class and Brown and
one of your friends says hey you know
I'm gonna apply it for grad school in
history or I'm applying for a job in
Wall Street or whatever you would say oh
I'm gonna go to Hollywood like you knew
the whole time you know that you were
studying history
the film was your thing yeah and when
you say the odds I mean I think you're
being a little bit fo humble that you
couldn't have been a doctor you
transferred a primary just kind of like
very dyslexic transfer to it well but I
couldn't have done what's the big the
coordinate chemistry no I mean not even
around that
not even close I in fact wiggled my way
through passing the key things and
Brownwood had no core curriculum right
right so I I wiggled my ran through high
school and did I worked really hard to
get sort of a c-minus average I'm not
boasting I'm not boasting in my life
happened to get into one of the most
selective and why he was very easy to
get into a 1982 very very easy but Brown
well and then I transferred to brown
after I did really well first freshman
year I see so I and I I was ambitious
but not
student interesting so you get I'm
suspicious of all of this even better
okay I really could not have been a
doctor earlier and then you go to
Hollywood I mean what are you telling
yourself you're you it sounds like you
knew the the odds so the art I'll give
you a quick arc yeah you know assistant
to somebody you know working you know
small jobs 10 years and it finally get
my break and I sold a script that a
friend of mine wrote to Warner Brothers
I was gonna direct it my big break it
was a training day with Denzel
Washington wow that's huge move and I
get fired I get fired I don't even get
to meet him I don't get to meet Denzel
Washington get fired this is my dream
this is what I've worked towards for 10
years and it was for all the wrong
reasons
and I just and I bought into this
Hollywood system I thought it was I
thought if I was a good soldier it would
pay off to me and if I did everything
right and it was gonna be a great movie
and it was a great movie and I was the
only one who wanted him in the role and
I got fired and it was so disillusioned
I hit rock bottom as a person and as a
director that I said screw it and I
bought a little $800 high eight camera
I'm gonna make a movie about people I
like and I made this film about
first-year teachers called the first
year first thing I ever did and I drove
to all these public schools all around
Los Angeles and Compton and wast in East
LA and I made my first movie a
documentary and I just felt right and
you were able to do it and it was mine
and the great thing about documentaries
is you can control the means of
production and that was the beginning of
it now all the means of production that
we use to make a documentary art can be
done in my office right in a way that
they couldn't have been done even in
documentaries only a few years earlier
but I sort of it was such a
devastatingly apocalyptic moment in my
life that I had no choice but to do
the thing that I had to do which is to
tell a story about someone I loved and
admired and and it was and it was I mean
you you're saying the documentary was an
important medium for you because you
could be in control of the story I mean
but all of what you've done
starting with that first documentary
until now has been there's been a social
justice piece of in fact there's always
been this narrative of maybe just
through this documentary you might be
able to move the dial in some way is
that well my father had some part of
that because he did a lot of social
justice documentaries and there was a
part I direct a lot of television to
which is very gratifying it you know
shows like 20 for ye are Deadwood and
really gratifying but there is there's a
bit of factory work to it my wife is on
the show CSI and there's a bit of hard
work routine work that the quality of
the job is so good the people who do it
are so good but there's something that
when I got the taste of it and I wanted
to do I wanted to be a big holler
director when I got a taste of it having
told stories made documentaries that had
some little fragment of this film is
going to not even do good but actually
have some kind of influence on a
conversation that might do good was
addictive right and now and and after
Inconvenient Truth which had never been
made and I never thought would do any
good but why should it never have been
made but after that movie I became a
junkie for it well that's a good enough
in maze so it was pitched to me like
they said we're gonna make some of these
people came to me how I knew and they so
here's a documentary what do you think
it's a documentary about climate change
I'm like okay I'm in I like that that's
good I'm Eve that that's an important
issue it's based on a slideshow that Al
Gore gave us I'm like okay no slideshow
you can't make a movie about a slideshow
and I mean I and I have great fondness
and respect for Al Gore but I don't
think you should make you feel about a
politician because it comes with its own
baggage no matter how much you like that
politics
can't be done and I said no terrible
idea and and and and what can so you
weren't at all enamored I mean obviously
National international figure it was a
hot topic was terrible idea
terrible idea so you'd kind of given up
on any of the oh this might be you know
this might be a super hit or anything
like that it was you just thought about
even when we had finished it yeah we
didn't think it was gonna do anything so
but what convinced you them to do it do
this terrible idea so the producers
Laurie David and Lawrence bender said
don't say no yet go to the Hilton where
he's gonna do this thing in front of the
luncheon and Al Gore walks on stage and
there and there
I remember this they were serving like
cold like it's supposed to be hot but
cold chicken mashed potatoes and like
bad gravy and you're like just sawing
into your chicken there's al gore's like
history of the planet oh my this lecture
slide show Al Gore
terrible idea and he really and the
graphics were like you know kind of
rudimentary
and then by the end of it I was by the
end of it there was this feeling that I
I think people have at the end of the
movie which is like holy [ __ ] this is
this is deep and this is urgent and and
I was physically shaken and it's a
really good lesson
I think it's filmmaking which is that
when your body feels something when you
feel something that you're not
convincing yourself to feel there's
something you have to listen to and that
clever is often misleading I'm gonna do
this movie because it's clever or I'm
gonna make that choice it was clever
instead of like following a feeling like
a response that you have trust that more
than trust clever and so you were I mean
so my chicken was like the gravy had
dried up
chicken was half-eaten the fork of the
knife or the left there but I was like
oh my gosh and even if I make this movie
and ten people see it that's a good
thing and I want other people to
understand what I just figured out so
the power of it was already there and I
don't know how to do this it's a great
thing I don't know how to do this a
slide show with a politician it makes no
sense but I have to do it so I've driven
by that overwhelming desire that the
cleverer sighted me said do not do it
wasn't a pattern here then you could Oh
like look up all the it's really very
profitable documentaries about
slideshows with politicians in them you
can't find it do you think about
profitability when you even for a
documentary no but I think about who's
gonna watch it it's a terrible feeling
and I've had this experience where you
make a movie and no one sees it right
it's heartbreaking
like you know it's heartbreaking when
you work really hard and you tell us to
write no one sees it all right but then
you you do it and it turns into it goes
where frankly documentaries have never
gone before it turns into a mainstream
right movie right and does that does
that change how you perceive yourself
what you do what what your next project
was going to be it puts more pressure on
you when when you've had a successful
film and there's a sort of expectation
on the next film I mean that that film
regardless of where someone is on the
political spectrum I mean that changed
the discussion that moved and that's a
lot of it a huge portion of it
Al Gore's work in building that
slideshow a huge part of it and
enlightening did strike like it was it
landed right when bush president george
w bush was starting to fall from grace
in the public's mind and so that was
helpful and people were starting to
reconsider gorras in his story
everything that sort of in the end
Katrina had just happened so all these
things sort of fit so it wasn't the
success of that movie was not
necessarily about
I think was actually had very little to
do with it well but the filmmaking work
yeah so the experience worked yeah I'm
not saying as filmmaking was poor
filmmaking worked the audience
experienced what I hoped they would
experience but its success had very
little to do with the filmmaking and so
now you do you feel pressure that you
kind of have to do something of that
magnitude again or it's not something I
feel like I have to probably will never
do it again but I'm a junkie for that
feeling but you kind of did it again
with Waiting for Superman I mean that
was another movie that really entered
the national conversation in a different
way I mean it's a more complicated
experience because it have a more
controversy involved in it but but so
but I'm a it's not about box office it's
about having a feeling like if I tell a
story maybe the conversation will change
that's exciting maybe people with this
movie will think maybe we changed their
minds about what a teacher is that'd be
cool that's true actually and it's fine
I I can ask you a question that I've
always wondered when waiting for support
why was it called Waiting for Superman
where did that wasn't you was it someone
else Geoffrey Canada had this great
thing Geoffrey Canada started this
incredible school in Harlem and he
talked about when he was a kid
the heartbreaking moment of his life was
when he realized that Superman was I
know and he was as a kid in the projects
and he thought that Superman could come
and help him because and give him some
power and save him and the day realized
that Superman wasn't real like I say and
so a sort of he sort of had that
metaphor already and so and I didn't
come up with the title
Leslie Chilcott the producer did but it
was like wow that's we're waiting in the
same way he was waiting for Superman and
now that you've done I mean frankly
several of these I mean whether or not
you admitted you're especially in
certain certain you're a household name
I mean is there a temptation to and a
couple in like three households oh no no
you know six million households
well make that assumption I mean is
there any temptation to go back I mean
there must have been a little pity part
of the Hollywood movie the the computer
graphics and the you know the real you
know there's no temptation to do
transformers for I would I I would love
to do another movie I've done a couple
and it have to be something really
special I wouldn't want to do
transformers 4 and so forth so there's
so much work yeah
and Michael Bay is so good at yeah no
I'm not it's not that Michael Bay needs
to be replaced right no no but I'm
saying like that's a different skill
right but I I'm a junkie for that I much
prefer to make documentaries much prefer
so what what if what would what would
have to be true about a commercial film
to to have you do it you know watch my
kids this weekend watch the movie 42
about Jackie Robinson
yeah and that did something very
different but did something that I love
and storytelling like they got to see a
moment and that's its most it's it's a
true story but it's fictionalized but
they just saw a great story and they
they learnt they they learning is not
the word it's their connecting to the
world they're connecting to the human
experience in a way in which some
sometimes movies can do and when that
happens that's pretty great and if I'm
part of that that's cool and do you
think I mean you started off wanting to
do a Hollywood movies do you think
you're inherently better at one of the
two types I made two feature movies then
I would call one a c-minus and the other
a d-plus would you mind saying what the
food so one was called called gossip
movie called gossip which is it you know
it's a sort of a genre movie it's okay I
did a pretty good job and the other was
a movie called Gracie which was this you
know it was pretty good so you weren't
really happy with how they turned out I
think I did a pretty good job I think I
would like a workmen's job yeah I would
say I'm not exceptional as a feature
director and and I know
so I the whole thing I am fascinated I
think I think i mean i'm personally
fascinated not i hope people listening
this would be too i mean it you kind of
glazed over that 10-year period between
college and write your first almost
break being this thing that changed your
view of yourself in the world i mean
that that's a fad I mean at ten years of
just kind of it sounds like you were
just taking whatever job you can your
ass to do just to get closer to being a
principal I mean did you ever think
about giving up on that and going yeah I
mean it's I directed a lot of episodic
television which is you know guest
director which means you're one of
twenty directors on a given show and I
when I hear about Malcolm Gladwell's
10,000 hours that rings really true to
me that there was there was a lot of
learning the form and repeating the form
and doing a pretty good job at the form
to then one day be better at it like the
Beatles
playing genre tunes that they didn't
write over and over again three nights a
weekend so I learned I learned a lot in
that era so you were getting work so to
speak you there was a sense of progress
I didn't right out of college you you
were able to get I mean what did you get
a first even guest director I'm so bad
at this dates and stuff so so I land in
LA in 1888 and I start directing in 93
so so you were live year 26 27 years old
but then you know you hit a certain how
does that happen I mean you resume how
do you get how do you even get that job
get your first job just banging it out
like you know making short films and
apprentice and so you had a portfolio of
short films that you would send to
people kind of and
and then I would observe I would I would
observe on other TV shows an unpaid job
standing next to directors pretending I
knew that I was doing and then one day
someone took a but even how do you get
how do you even get that you just just
ask I mean I don't think if I called up
some random director for CSI or
something so yeah hang out with me right
how do you how do you get there it took
a while I mean part of us getting the
job is the low paying job on another
show and then you you know and the low
paying job is anything from a PA
production assistant I see and that's
something that you have submitted a
resume for and it producers a system and
then you sort of like the great think
the nice thing about Hollywood is that
it's it is entrepreneurial it's like you
don't have to go to graduate school pass
the bar you can you can worm your way
through the system and find a place do
you think Hollywood eventually finds the
real talent that's out there do you
think a lot of people get lost in this
in this that's interesting I think
talent is so rare in Hollywood like let
me put it differently
scratch that I think there's
extraordinarily great talent in all the
crafts you know cinematographers sound
people art direction wardrobe incredible
people you can find incredible people
and the depth of those people is
incredible and the way Hollywood keeps
make getting them better is incredible
technology digital stuff but I think the
part that's really hardest and I think
anyone intuitively gets this is it
the lack of great scripts and
storytelling so the unique story that's
the hardest part there's so few great
scripts that they end up making more
than they have good scripts for one
thing that I'm curious I mean what's
your sense of does does everyone who
shows up in Hollywood and has talent do
they eventually get found recognized I
think there's a there's a certain
persistence factor so I'm sure there's a
very talented
walk away so that's probably happens but
if you're good and you stay for a while
and you keep banging on the door and
you're good and you've got something to
say I think you'll be found and how do
you know you're you're you're that and
not someone who's on a kind of a fool's
errand well that happens to I know a lot
of people who have written 100 scripts
and nothing gets made and for some
reason it doesn't work I mean is there
any clue is there anything you told
yourself in those 10 year period where
you were doing that you were being
persistent where were you you said well
that's a dead one that shows that I have
some talent but if I just persist
something Goods gonna happen you're on
to something that question is the
ultimate question and you know so you
don't know it you see it you know and
there was many many years where I really
wondered whether I had anything at all
to say and I for a long time felt there
was nothing to say and I think if you
said to Davis when he was even 30 30 or
35 you think you'll ever tell a story of
any significance in my heart of hearts I
would have said no and is that is that
answer is that question the same as do
you think I would be successful it's a
different question and so because in
that early period you were still you're
going after commercial Hollywood
production and where success is very
different than yes so I was a I was a
sought-after television director yeah
but I don't I didn't I wasn't I wasn't
my own storyteller I was in service of
someone else's story
I see so in that 10-year period you did
have a momentum to your career that you
were getting more responsibility more
prestigious responsibilities to direct
things and I had a chair with my name on
it
yeah and I was a member of a guild and I
made a good living but but I wasn't
doing what I came to Hollywood to do
which is to somehow tell a story how
long did it take you to get to that
point where you said wow I can I can pay
the bills with this
eight years okay so it's yeah like the
longest eight years of my life so that
eight years so there wasn't a period
where you felt like gee I'm just gonna
stop this huh you know some of my
friends wouldn't become became
accountants and they can buy their you
know buy a nice car and they have a down
payment on the house yeah absolutely
and so I do think there's a persistence
factor there sort of like showing up and
doing the work and and and did you quit
knocking on knocking on a hundred doors
for one to open but you were your so
this whole eight year figure is kind of
just getting by with the they were film
related jobs that you were doing little
jobs and some of them were not paying
well and some of them were dead ends and
but you didn't have to wait tables and
that type of traditional story I took
some bad jobs
I took some you know I edited a
conference for the CIA that seems
interesting so they did a and all the
old spies come out and talk about the
Cuban Missile Crisis but they're all in
their 70s and 80s and there were two
Hilton and there and the sound was bad
they were standing in a podium and they
said here's thirty hours of footage can
you cut it down to one and I did that I
mean on paper it was a it was a terrible
job because it was it was never gonna go
anywhere
no one wasn't gonna do anything but on a
fascination level was great and so but
so the good thing is even at those early
days you were able to pay your bills
doing something in your craft it wasn't
the most glamorous thing barely barely
you really get something you know I was
a guy that was someone the producer's
assistant for a assistant for a long
time picking up dry cleaning making
phone calls so there was a lot of grunt
work and this portfolio of stuff this
was just like we you and her friends
with the camcorders that you would
produce are you how did you how are you
able to do a little bit of a break
because I worked on this film Sex Lies
and videotape I remember that and my
boss couldn't pay me so he gave me
tenth of a point so a thousandth of a
piece of a movie no hundreds no a
thousandth of a movie I wasn't of a
movie and I was like well this is a
low-budget movie no one's ever gonna see
it and it turned out to be worth $30,000
in 1990 was it even 90 something so I
$30,000 and I made a short film with
that sounds like this little gift I
remember that movie distinctly because
my uncles wanted to see it and they were
babysitting me so they took me and my
cousin and they gave us $20 in arcade
tokens in the movie theater and said
we're gonna watch this movie now and you
didn't go you just no well they because
you ran it was like I think it was
barely rated R right wasn't it even on
those do you ever just dig memory of not
being allowed to see it but I got $20 in
tokens to spend the next two hours at
the arcade because my uncle's wanted to
see it they're probably very
disappointed it was a very deep art film
very little like fun gratuitous I see so
that was would you do would you point
pin point that is kind of the break that
Elijah was one of the breaks and give
you a lot of you know I think luck is a
part of it I think being ready when luck
happens is a big part of it like
sometimes if your luck breaks and you're
not ready you got to be ready when the
luck happens see the door will open but
then you got to walk through it and do
something did you know people in
Hollywood who you just think they're
just the most amazing talent and they're
just they just got squandered I mean
yeah and or sometimes they're stuck yeah
you know they're stuck working on a show
that's paying enough money to put their
family through but they doing exactly
what they want to do it's really lucky
to be able to find something or you can
tell your own stories and have the
independence to have it all sometimes
it's like money and security or doing
your own thing
and having your independence it was
always some combination I very people of
both very few people and you do
probably more documentaries aren't ya
don't make it I I make a good living but
not the kind of living you'd make if you
were a big Hollywood dude
right right but so there's a little bit
of a compromise but I'll I've I picked
independence and my own stuff over
big-name success and big money success
and there's a there's always a sort of a
choice between those two doors and you
ever regret the choice you made I think
everyone is always always thinks about
that the return of like we working at no
brain and I do I think well what if I
had done that and one of and you know
but I think I've won the jackpot yeah
because I have the I love this job
I like being where you are which is
meeting people and asking questions and
learning the job keeps filling you up
right and in the independence to sort of
choose my stuff and this stuff I do is
pretty great
did your your dad's passed away now he
saw my very first film on the first year
the first film I did we talked about and
then what did he think of it so that was
one of the great memories I have is that
we are screening in Washington and I
left to go to the bathroom it's dark and
I saw him watch the movie and he didn't
see me watching him watch the movie so I
got to see him sort of watch my movie
and that was and he was smiling and
enjoying it and I could tell that he he
liked it did you tell that to you later
on no I just saw that and you know he he
was very few civ with praise but if you
but kids start to hear that praise and
they start to not believe it
yeah so I got to see it I got to see it
without him trying to praise me I get to
feel his praise without him having to
give it to me and so he and he was
supportive of this the whole time that
you were pursuing the movie I may was
not the kind of
he would make it was the opposite of
what he would make and yet he still
appreciate it that was the best part it
wasn't making his movies this wasn't a
documentary this was this is a career
this was the first year this year this
did you fully had made right yeah you
made the commercial films after that
before I made one of the commercial the
most of my television career was before
that right right and he'd seen that
stuff yeah what are your siblings do
decide Cassie my brother is a filmmaker
my sisters are produced as documentaries
so you're right you're right about that
whole doctor though it just wasn't even
a boston to generate thing you know
there's no word there's no now there's
not degenerative like being a doctor as
bad it's just that once your parent is a
filmmaker right your doc oh I
yeah doctors teachers great but I just
hard to go back right that maybe I'm
using the wrong word Yeah right yeah
yeah progressive you're in yeah it's
kind of limiting it recommended you to
that universe right right oh it's not a
bad universe well thank you this was
really really fun it's an honor to be in
your office sitting in your office it's
an honor to hear you say that